This is an example of the GMail inbox
displayed using a feature called
High Contrast Mode.
High Contrast Mode allows
the user to invert foreground and
background colors which may help
the tech stand out a lot better.
For someone with a little vision
impairment High Contrast Mode can make
it much easier to navigate
the content of the page.
And there's a few ways to get high
contrast set up on your machine.
Operating systems like Mac, OS X and
Windows offer High Contrast Modes that
can be enabled for
everything at the system level.
Here's an example of the high
contrast controls from the Mac
accessibility system preferences.
I can go on and I can turn on
invert colors, increase contrast.
And there's also a slider so
I can fine tune the amount of contrast,
I would like to have.
Similarly users can install an extension
like the Chrome High Contrast
extension to only enable high
contrast in that specific app.
Now a useful exercise is to turn
on high contrast settings and
verify that all of your
UI is still visible.
For example, this navigation bar
uses a very subtle background
color to indicate which
item is currently selected.
If I view it using Chrome's
high contrast extension,
that background color pretty
much completely disappears and
with it goes my understanding of
which page is currently active.
Similarly, if we check out our form
example from the previous lesson,
that red underline on
the invalid phone number field
is now showing up as sort of
a bright bluish green color.
Thankfully, we added
a message down there to
tell us what's wrong with the field.
Now if you're meeting the contrast
ratios we covered in the previous
lessons, you should be okay when it
comes to supporting high contrast users.
But for added peace of mind,
consider installing the Chrome High
Contrast extension and giving your page
a once over just to double check
that everything works as expected.